[Musique]
1938 deux chercheurs allemands
découvrent la fission nucléaire
c'était il ya 80 ans ce phénomène
survient lorsqu'on dit vise le coeur
d'un atome son maillot en de nouveau à
ton plus léger
cette découverte bouleverse le monde de
la physique
comment les chercheurs sont ils parvenus
à cette prouesse scientifique
déjà au début des années 30 l'atom est
sous le feu des projecteurs
de nombreux physiciens s'intéresse donc
scientifiques italiens enrico fermi
fermi bombarde le noyau de 60 éléments
différents avec des neutrons une
particule qu'on vient tout juste de
découvrir
il constate que l'uranium et agit
bizarrement au contact d'une trop ou
loyaux d'uranium éjectent des particules
le physicien qu'on pût qu'il s'agit
d'éléments nouveaux créés à partir de la
réaction atomique
[Musique]
le 22 décembre 1938 otto hahn et son
assistant fritz strassmann répète
l'expérience
elle réalise alors que le physicien
italien s'est trompé quand on envoie un
neutron sur son noyau l'uranium ne
produit pas de nouveaux éléments
il se fracture plutôt en plusieurs
morceaux des atomes plus léger mais
aussi des neutrons et de l'énergie pour
baptise le phénomène fission nucléaire
[Musique]
fermi reprend la balle au bond il saisit
le potentiel énorme de cette découverte
si des neutrons sont éjectés on peut les
envoyer sur d'autres noyaux d'uranium
à leur tour ces boyaux dégage des
neutrons et de l'énergie c'est la
réaction en chaîne
elle récupère me comprend comment la
contrôler et produire une quantité
phénoménale d'énergie
c'est cette réaction qui permettra aux
centrales nucléaires de générer de
l'électricité
[Musique]
mais les utilisations des plus
spectaculaires de la réaction en chaîne
sont aussi des plus dévastatrices
en 1945 les états unis l'arc deux bombes
nucléaires sont vus japonaises
d'hiroshima et de nagasaki
pendant les décennies qui suivent
plusieurs pays testent leurs propres
armes atomiques
par la suite c'est est devenu
souterrains sont plus rares
quant à l'énergie nucléaire aujourd'hui
elle suscite encore des craintes liées
aux risques d'explosion du réacteur et à
l'enfouissement des déchets en médecine
toutefois les produits radioactifs
utilisés lors d'examens demeure d'une
grande utilité
[Musique]